- (homme): Et on aura l'occasion
d'évoquer avec lui frère.. frèr.
- Sur la ligne d'arrivée,
Hugo Houle a partagé sa victoire
avec son petit frère, décédé en
2012, heurté par un chauffard.re
une étape du Tour,
pour son frère et pour lui.
HUGO HOUremier Tech
- C'était mon rêve de gagner
une étapde France.
Un rêve un peu fou. J'avais
jamais gagné une course
avant auhui, je gagne.
Complètement fou, mais...
ait, puis je suis sûr
que mon frère m'a aidé.
1 ans, Hugo Houle est
le premier Québécois à remporter
une étape du Tour de France,
34 ans a34 ans a34 ans a34 ans .
Steve Bauer est aujourd'hui
le directeur sportif de
l'équipe d'Hugo Houle et de
Michael Woods, Israel-Premier
d'affaires israélo-canadien
Sylvan Adams. le Québécois
s'est adjugé en solitaire
la 16e éla 16e éla 16e éla 16e e
à la porte des Pyrénées.
- (homme): Hugo Houle, quelcour!
- Excellent rouleur, Hugo Houle
s'est porté en tête au 140e km.
en tête, le dernier mur
de l'étape, 9 km, à 8 %.): Si Ht
pas à la faute, il faut beaucoup
ité, il ira décrocher
une magnifique victoire
ô combien méritée.
- Michael Woods a fait
avail d'équipier
à la perfection pour protéger
l'avance du Québécois.
- Champion Houle!
- Arms up all the way!
- Wouh!
- Dans la voiture de l'équipe,
Steve Bauer a suivi avec émotion
les derniers mètres
du rouleur de 31 ans.
- (homme): Il est heureux,
on peut le comprendre,
donc, le Québécois.
Donc, la Belle Province,- Woodsé
3e au sein d'un petit groupe,
à 70 secondes de son coéquipier,
partager son émotion.
(cris de joie)isée française
a qualifié de remarquable
la perfougo Houle,
qui a d'ailleurs remporté
le prix de la combativité.
Ici Philippe Crépeau,
Radio-Canada, Mon